with their extravagant lifestyles their
private jets their expensive homes and
their love for glitz russia's richest
have suddenly found themselves on a
wartime hit list
those connected to vladimir putin those
who help him those who protect him now
facing a financial onslaught
this week the government will introduce
its economic crime bill designed to
clamp down on russians who use london to
launder money there are over a hundred
billionaires in russia
we have compiled a hit list of oligarchs
we're working through and putting the
cases together and every few weeks we
will sanction new oligarchs there will
be a rolling program of sanctions we
will go through the hit list we're
targeting oligarchs private jets uh
we'll be targeting their properties uh
we'll be targeting uh other possessions
that they have and there will be nowhere
to hide
the foreign secretary refused to say
whether the chelsea owner and
billionaire roman abramovich was on the
list
after 19 years mr abramovic yesterday
said he was passing stewardship to the
trustees of the club's charitable
foundation he still owns chelsea and so
far he's not condemned putin for his
actions
the owner might not be commenting but
the players showed their support wearing
the ukraine national colours on their
strips today but what about the fans
maybe it would be good for him to do
like a further like clarification as to
where he stands if he wants to stay or
go home to russia he's not going to
upset putin isn't it football's
important but people's lives are more
important
whoever becomes the target of economic
sanctions experts say it'll take time in
reality how complicated is that and how
effective can it be we're talking about
jets we're talking about property um you
know we're talking about all types of
other possessions and
and things like that that they've got um
around the world so it's difficult to
say you know that those sanctions are
going to make a significant impact here
in the uk i think if we're able to
coordinate that globally with the
european union with the united states
with other countries that's certainly
going to have much more of an impact
these tough new measures are designed to
hurt those closest to putin figures who
until now have seemed untouchable now
clear targets in this new war nick
martin sky news